[Music]
you think of yourself as a confident man
no people think like you know doing
stand-up and stuff is like it's like a
confident I've never felt confident I
think it's I think it's because when I
was a kid the bar for confidence for me
was set like super high oh really
yeah you know someone who was super
confident well I was like eight years
old I'm at my friend's birthday party
where is this this is in Karachi
Pakistan okay and he's also like turning
a or whatever I just mean we're all kids
I'm not going to like a 34 year olds
birthday right and I'm talking to a
friend of mine and we're just talking
and I don't know what we're talking
about but while I'm talking to him I
noticed that this kid has like pooped
himself but this it's fun like a little
bit this is like the days you know this
is like in his into his his trouser into
his trousers and it's just there and
he's just like talking to me and
laughing and like gesturing and and I I
noticed that and I'm not trying to call
him out I just noticed it and I go oh
hey you have poop in your pants and he
looks at me dead in the eyes and he goes
that's not poo that's party cream and
then once you've got another slice of
cake confident is back here
Marty cream what is he talking about
well I was like the wall he must be
right yeah look at his gate yes I too
have swagger in that situation
oh hi I beg to disagree my friend yeah
because and I came home to my mom I was
like I need party Kris this is true I
don't know why I'm talking about this
yeah okay this was not there was one
time I did myself Conan okay I did I
swear to God I was not trying to steer
us at all into this collection
[Applause]
this is this is actually it hasn't been
announced this your pants we come
tomorrow I'll rope ya so go ahead tell
it tell us this other words talking
about this like like two years ago okay
I don't don't get it okay because I and
I wasn't I wasn't sick or anything
I was at work and it was I didn't even
need to I didn't even feel like I needed
to go to the bathroom it was like one
moment there was no poop in my pants
it almost felt like someone else my
parents
did you did you ever figure out what
happened there pal I assume I why did I
ask for more why and you know no why did
I dig further
well did you did you go home from work
did you just knock it off the party
cream yeah really want to know the
details I'll tell you what do you think
we want to hear you push your show right
here you clean your beds I was working I
was shooting something yeah and I'm
waiting to go out some wearing laughs
wearing their clothes oh my god was
wardrobe oh wow oh you're the word I
swear this is completely true I'm in my
trailer waiting to go out and I'm
playing I swear it's a game called
Temple Run on my iPad where we all know
Temple Run and then like I said I am you
play when you're constipated it works
every time you didn't know that Temple
runs
so why am I doing this I don't know I
don't know it just happened
well we're here now and you were wearing
you're wearing the clip the it shows
clothes I'm wearing the shows clouds I'm
playing temple run nope nope in my pants
and then suddenly there is a magic trick
you make it sound like David Copperfield
is there
[Applause]
you